what do we say the Beats were going to
be the beat goes
[Music]
on season two it's going to be totally
different this year is about taking my
power back no more designers don't
listen to anybody just do it yourself no
more
gardeners this year we have to do manual
labor Ary is My Sanctuary so I need to
be the one to make
decisions where's my welcoming committee
where's the boys but I'm also going to
be bringing in my kids the
Anderson Brandon and Dylan lived in La
they just bought a new house together
you pick like the perfect house life
changer and I'm going to help them
renovate it Dylan is it your
Vibe we're renovating the entire house
we have to have a lot of vision to
figure this out we're going to make it
our style I don't really like any of
those we're going to crush it wait a
second this is not even like the same
place
real nice I have an
idea I'll help them with our project
they're going to help me on Vancouver
Island because really this is a family
property and I want their input I bought
Ary 30 years ago from my grandmother
last year we renovated the roadh house
the old
cabin the Rose Garden and the pier which
is amazing I love
it last year I thought we were going to
do the boat house but there's a very
small piece of this boat house that's
sitting on government land so we have to
purchase it so that's what we're waiting
for this thing is just a it's going to
happen you have to have a lot of
patience it's crazy I am positive I am
hopeful while we're waiting for permits
this is the updated site plan we have
plenty of other projects to do I'm more
excited about this than anything this
this we have more buildings to build the
cabins are going to be here I want to
build a lot more cabins here
parent cluster that's you o look at the
big dick I want to recreate what my
grandmother had here before the front of
the house we're putting an orchard
in got a little room for garden I think
we want to expand the vegetable garden
and the flower garden because we want to
have cut flowers the arcadey flower shop
I think it's great everything on this
property is going to be used canned
eaten giv away no waste it's going to be
a big Nursery SL Farmers Market SL
flower store this is so exciting feels
like we're going forward I mean I don't
even know if it's possible I've never
done anything like this before so we're
going to experiment there's no rules no
rules in this house
anyway so what's the end goal with this
gate we've just made this a family
project we don't need anybody
else I'm just glad this is a group
effort now I know there were tears last
year there'll probably be tears this
year it'll be me though somebody has to
be the villain now it's
Brandon
oh is a lot like me was passionate it's
only up from here right there lots to do
all right let's go I'm
[Music]
excited